can you survive this prime minister
leaving downing street now the subject
of a police investigation and hoping to
persuade his party in parliament to move
on from the parties in number 10. in
truth many people have already decided
whether they believe boris johnson over
what's referred to as partygate the
latest twist including one loyal mp
claiming the prime minister had been
ambushed with a birthday cake at a
celebration in june 2020.
in parliament johnson was asked yet
again about his assurances last month
that there'd be no parties and that no
kovid 19 rules have been broken
the minister of code
says that ministers who knowingly
mislead parliament will be expected to
offer their resignation
does the prime minister believe that
applies to him
prime minister mr speaker of course but
let me tell the house that i think he's
inviting a question about an
investigation which is you know mr
speaker i can't comment
johnson brushed off calls to resign
saying he had important work to do but
top of his inbox will be the government
report overseen by civil servant sue
gray into a series of gatherings in
downing street since the first lockdown
in 2020. so can the prime minister
confirm that he will publish the full
sue grey report as he receives it
mr speaker what i can tell him is that
we've got to leave the report to the
independent uh investigators he knows
and of course
when i receive it i of course i will do
exactly what i said
as part of the report police officers
working here gave evidence that evidence
led the metropolitan police to decide
they would launch their own
investigation into potential breaches of
covid laws
anyone found guilty could receive a fine
but the mere fact the prime minister
could be interviewed as a suspect adds a
layer of embarrassment to widespread
public resentment
if the
investigation proved that he was uh
breaking the rule then yes definitely he
was breaking the rule because a lot of
people are dying that time people are
following it strictly it was definitely
against the spirit of what we were all
trying to do as a nation
yeah and if he's broken the law then bye
as speculation mounted about how many
conservative mps might soon be sending
in letters to trigger a no-confidence
vote in johnson's leadership the foreign
secretary was wearily defending her boss
on national television
i'm 100 supportive of the prime minister
he has done a great job
whether it's delivering brexit whether
it's the response the pandemic
there's no doubt the shines come off
boris johnson's image as a man of the
people but it's his colleagues not the
public having to decide right now
whether he can come back from this or
whether he's become too much of a
liability nadim baba al-jazeera